the last decade has been pretty great
for science fiction films but while not
every brilliant recent sci-fi flick is
worth owning and revisiting time and
time again some definitely are here are
a few modern classics that are so fun
engaging and compelling that they are
totally worth three exploring over and
over for years to come
moon directed by Duncan Jones the
amazing movie moon takes place in pretty
much one location and for the most part
it focuses on just one actor making the
haunting end results or the more
brilliant the story follows astronaut
Sam Bell played by Sam Rockwell who
lives all alone on the moon mining the
dusty satellite for fuel bells only
company is a creepy robot named gertie
but that all changes when Belle
discovers a second astronauts who looks
just like him
naturally this discovery causes both
doppelgangers to question their own
existence a smart intriguing film with a
small budget but big ideas that
mysteries of moon never grow old largely
thanks to his charismatic leading man
Mad Max fury road the pinnacle of George
Miller's career fury road is - a journal
in laced hours of incredible stunt work
breathtaking cinematography and badass
warrior women riding through the desert
and big rigs and on motorcycles it's
essentially one long incredible chase
scene with some of the most amazing set
pieces ever put on the big screen
there's the epic sandstorm sequence the
death-defying climax involving bad guys
dropping in and out of the action on
massive poles and dozens more instantly
iconic moments that deserve to be
witnessed again and again including of
course the doof warrior wielding his
flame-throwing guitar attack the block
this charming British thriller follows a
gang of South London Street toughs who
find themselves in the middle of an
alien invasion
surrounded by freakish ape creatures
with lion-like teeth the teens decide to
press pause on their criminal careers
and take on the extraterrestrials using
everything from baseball bats to fire
crackers to defeat their of a worldly
foes attack the block is a
crowd-pleasing jam that expertly mixes
carnage and comedy
she's safe on top of us we genuinely
come to care about our heroes especially
Moses the leader of the group who's
played by none other than future Star
Wars phenom john-boy Jaeger the Martian
based on the best-selling novel of the
same name
the Martian stars Matt Damon as Mark
Watney an American astronaut
accidentally abandoned on Mars left to
fend for himself what he is determined
to stay alive until help arrives but how
is one mere earthling supposed to
survive the cold indifference of the Red
Planet
it's exciting to watch what neat puzzle
is way out of one problem after another
whether it's communicating with NASA or
growing the first Martian potatoes the
film is so fun to revisit because it's a
rare sincere love letter to human
achievement if nothing else the Martian
proves our watching people who are good
at their jobs can be addictive inception
a truly groundbreaking sci-fi film
Christopher Nolan's inception wowed
audiences and critics alike with its
mind-bending visuals and brilliantly
layered action sequences the story moves
with the speed of a runaway train
following a group of dream thieves as
they pull the ultimate heist if a movie
is full of twists and turns are so with
every viewing there's an opportunity to
analyze a new detail or catch some fresh
clue you never really remember the
beginning of a dream do you always wind
up right in the middle of what's going
on I guess yeah so how did we end up
here as a result the movie has spawned
countless fun theories proving that when
it comes to rewatch ability inception is
a dream come true looper you knew this
one was coming if you're in the mood for
some mind-bending fun it's always a safe
bet to relive the past and revisit Ryan
Johnson's looper this time-travel thrill
of follows Joseph gordon-levitt as Joe a
hitman who works for the mob in 2044 his
job is to execute victim sent back in
time from 2070 for the things get a bit
complicated when the gangsters send back
his older self played by Bruce Willis in
addition to some breathtaking action
sequences the movie also grapples with
weighty issues like the cyclical nature
of violence and features Joseph
gordon-levitt sporting custom facial
prosthetics and
take lenses to pull off some impressive
younger Bruce Willis cosplay even if he
does kind of look a little more like a
young Alec Baldwin it's got everything
you need for the perfect repeat viewing
experience edge of tomorrow if there was
ever a movie meant to be relived over
and over again
it's 2014's edge of tomorrow kind of
like a Groundhog Day with guns this
military thriller follows a cowardly
major played by Tom Cruise who keeps
experiencing the same day over and over
again
too bad the day in question involves a
massive alien invasion and the only gets
to start it over after he's been
violently killed of course this freaky
form of eternal life has its advantages
the fun here comes from watching crews
adjusting each new day to the dangers at
hand and slowly becoming a genuine war
hero and while cruisers character might
get tired of repeatedly seeing the same
events over and over again sci-fi fans
will love revisiting a gem like this day
after day after day find me when you
wake up
watch come find me when you wait thanks
for watching
take the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]